[Music]
in ex-336 england music the next web
ah
my house is like a museum open to
the Latin American world I think there will be
some 100,000 pieces of music, a
collection the coast of LPs
that we will have some 50,000 million pesos records  of
45 revolutions the 78 revolutions 40
thousand cds
also transports music to places
that almost nothing transports me it is a
drug for me
my name is alejandra fy regleta better
known as gladys palma and I am a
collector of Latin music of
all time I have always
Latin America was very close to me, my father
worked a lot there, my mother was from
Panama and since she was a little girl she started
listening to this type of music when
she was 4 or 5 years old.
I started collecting when I
lived in Panama for a year when I was 18.
Well, here in the collection.  we have
music from practically all the countries
of Latin America
we are really going to complete the best of
the best of Latin music because I think
that everyone has  right to
access all of this, not just a few,
I think we have to delve much
deeper into the roots of this music to
understand the number of groups that
there have been of chachachá, boogaloo or
mambo, you go deeper and deeper
and you really get to  realize what
it means and the importance that it
has, we are
not doing this for myself,
my idea is to share this entire collection
with everyone and the desire has been to be
able to deliver this
collection tomorrow to an institution to be able to
put it on  the disposition of an audience
anyone can come here or
where the collection is going to end and to be
able to express all this,
each record that is here has a
history and has a particularity
Latin America is a range of music is
that it is that I every day every  day i discover i
discover and i am surprised i dedicate myself to
this basically out of passion it gives me a
lot of pleasure to be able to divulge this and
this is the world of gladys
palma [Mús  ica]
uneven typical bodegas ams like
you can go back to the saint from the front the only thing
[Music]
let's see what those annoying
world service sandwiches and bodega drinks would
be the same
ok I was born in the Dominican Republic I used to
go to the radio stations that I
said  I really like this I want to
do this because I moved to New
York in 1999 well I started radio
here 4 years ago
there is no winery that I know of that has a
radio like me here in the winery
I am an
animal automatically  among the radios it is
dj or vox
all that was mine fm and I go to
the dj booth beyond the scope from the friend
a word that as it is said that I am
flirting flirty then we already got
names from tram fm because it deserved it
is not the change the  change the name
good afternoon live my works represents
the latin community here in brooklyn is
new york we have a reach of more or less
40,000 to 60,000 people he tried to
please everyone a little with his music
one is  urban
music a romantic music merengue
bachata
with classical music
so I decided to bring it all to a
single radio station
[Music]
re lanbide fm we are more focused not
only music is a stud
involved with the community these new
york' a long time ago it was a
very  bad I say that we were going to invite the
people to listen to the radio to the
community meetings and try to
fix the problems that we have here
we want to remind you that
whatever concerns you have it is
very important that you attend the
meetings thanks to the people of 375 and
in community that they are together with
us we are doing a
good job the support we are
having in the community after the
radio
[Music]
and powerful broadcast in the westin is quite a lot is carl
bernstein see the future in sports
are the world in  link so that in your
del ariscal see william daley
[Music]
the rest of the world on expect
latin nationals such a  s t-shirts
today renew that's why video
[Music]
[Applause]
we have clemente ruiz I love my decision
but being famous
the biggest escape events live
the great writer language contain schalke
time to drain music floured 2009
[Music
] racing
in the  friendship exists class
[Music]
the one who would be there thinks penalties in
medline days negotiating level we are
your time line la tele me the news
letter word' sport my youth we
organize this event you explain no band
for us
the dishlatino racket that the level of
tractors changes  of the team have
been here you will be able to play dolphins the
path of bryant lakers and with the
headline living solar the album the words the one
of repsol
bynum shows he entrusted me with the attitude of
boats both eseverri personal with
action
[Music]
the mariachi flower  from toloache is jeffrén
we have
work for dinner series women the types
of mariachi spin-off mexico the male spin-off mind
[Música]
observed links
to this mission
[Música]
[Músi  ca]
bernstein
the
language mariachi
[Music]
well we're going to be
leave salt on the index for a maximum of two
years
[Music]
on the team
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]